[Music]
well thank you very much I'm here to
talk about one of the aspects of my book
the new serfdom which talks about the
baleful effects of the economic guru
Frederick Hayek and the fact that mrs.
Thatcher thought everything he said was
rather good and put quite a lot of it
into effect along with Ronald Reagan
creating what I call a world that's
really shaped by the ideas of market
fundamentalism that markets should
actually get to make most of the
decisions in all and every aspect of our
existence and that the market encroaches
further and further and further into
that decision-making process and the
last thing that you should actually want
to see happen in any civilized society
is that the state or the Democratic
collective Express of the state should
maybe have some opinions about how
things ought to be provided what should
be available that aren't necessarily
connected to market mechanisms and so
this book is about that there are
aspects of that that I want to
particularly address today in the talk
which is is entitled work doesn't pay
and it's about the paradox of what's
been happening in our labor market for
the last 40 years and where we have
ended up now I want to talk about some
of the basic shapes and structures
around that market but I also want you
all to bear in mind the fact that as
well as the influence of deregulation
and market fundamentalism on our labor
market we it is now being assailed by a
period of some of the largest change
we're ever likely to see in our
lifetimes which is the impact of the
fourth Industrial Revolution the digital
revolution and what's actually happening
with that which is
another issue presenting us with huge
challenges for the future which will
complicate how we try to respond and use
the benefits of these new technologies
to help everybody rather than just
enrich a few people and I think just in
passing on that whenever you have huge
technological change forces are created
which tend to enrich a few people very
much indeed and create such change in
disruption for others that they become
impoverished we've seen it in all our
industrial revolutions but I think that
if we assert ourselves as a democracy
and as a state and as a polity as a
people as a society we can actually make
sure that we ensure that the benefits of
these changes and disruptions that are
coming our way very very rapidly and at
an increasing rate can actually be
shared more widely and that we can get
through this time of disjunction with a
lot more fairness and equity than we
would in the absence of that kind of
ambition to manage it so let's go back
to the paradox of our labor market
because whenever our current government
and I'm not being party political
obviously you wouldn't expect me to be
that way at an event like this whenever
it wants to boast about something it
boast about how fantastically successful
the labor market is and it always talks
in quantitative terms about how many
jobs have been created how we have the
largest number of people in employment
ever in our history partially because
our populations increase but that's
that's another issue and large amounts
of new jobs are being created it's all
very dynamic and wonderful but at the
same time the satisfaction levels for
some employees are so high and this job
satisfaction and yet at the same time
and alongside the mothers are struggling
to make ends meet and they're never
being able to
escape in work poverty and insecurity so
we've got this paradox going on which
you can resolve I think if you've looked
behind some of the headline figures
about quantity and start looking about
quality of the sorts of jobs that are on
offer so we have to consider what is
happening to quality in the job market
rather than just thinking about numbers
of jobs and taking this perspective it
actually becomes clear that there's an
increasing segmentation in our labor
market into what what I've being
characterized as lovely and lousy jobs
and if you're in the lovely sector
you've got your own pension you know
what your hours are you're probably
progressing you know that you can be
promoted you're shoring up your pension
you've got a holiday paying sick pay
time off agency at work and all of those
things and you're having great time and
it's very fulfilling you feel as a human
being that you're that you're helping
provide a service in a collective way
whatever it is you're doing and you're
enjoying your job that's the lovely end
and then at the lousy end this is very
very different the lousy end tends to be
jobs which are on minimum wage it tends
to be jobs where the hours aren't
guaranteed and can go down as well as up
also quite often where there's a great
deal of insecurity and a genuine no
knowledge whatsoever about the hours
that you'll be guaranteed in the future
but your costs stay the same quite often
it might be a zero hours contract it
might be a part-time work contract or an
agency contract and so you can't
guarantee your hours going forwards and
yet your outgoings are all too
predictably the same at the same time
the pay rises aren't happening and your
pay has probably been stagnant for at
least ten years and you're not getting
real terms pay increases but say
time if you're in the private rented
sector rents are going up costs are
going up the cost of utilities are going
up so you are actually in the situation
where you're working but you're not
making any progress and you can't
actually see an end to that kind of
treadmill that you're on employers quite
often won't say their employers and now
make you contract separately and if you
do that if you become apparently
self-employed or you incorporate that
can be a good choice if you're a
freelancer who can command a huge price
but all too often it's done as a sort of
scam to ensure that your employer
doesn't have to your employer doesn't
have to take on the cost of sick pay pay
national insurance give you holiday pay
or have any responsibilities towards you
if circumstances change so we're now in
a modern economy which is shaped by the
forces of market fundamentalism which
were unleashed by mrs. Thatcher and
we've got this segmented labor market
which is increasingly segmented between
lovely and lousy jobs and one in eight
of those at work now are classified as
poor so this is not a small number of
people at the margins this is actually
one in eight of those at work so they
work but work doesn't really pay and
there's little progression you can't
progress from a job in the lousy sector
to a job in the lovely sector the to a
segmented away if you're in one it's
it's very difficult to get out of the
lousy sector into a different sort of
sector and research shows that five out
of six people who find themselves in in
work poverty cannot get out of it within
a ten year period so they are facing a
kind of treadmill where there's no
obvious way out that they can't work
their way out or promote their way out
or do anything like that they're just
stuck in the last twenty five years
what's happened is that
poverty in work those who are work but
are still poor has risen from 5% of the
working population now to 18% so it's an
increasing feature and I think that in
the absence of government regulation or
action to regulate employer abuses
redefine what employment might mean
ensure that employers who are trying to
get out of their responsibilities to
workers or actually have the law
enforced it's very difficult to see this
getting any better and we know that
Frederick Hayek and famously mrs.
Thatcher loathed trade unions and they
legislated against the effectiveness of
trade unions because they saw them as a
way that those who were work for a
living and who who labor could actually
make a reasonable amount of reward from
those who were owners of capital and
we've seen ever since that happened in
the trade union acts in the 1980s the
number of people in trade unions has
fallen so in the private sector it's now
less than 15 percent of workers in a
trade union and it's under 50% in the
public sector as well so now
increasingly people's wages aren't
decided by collective bargaining or
collective action they decided in
one-to-one relations with a an employer
or they are just pronounced upon and the
employer employee likes it or lumps it
so insecurity precariousness lack of
employment protections all of them in
their own way suppress wages it makes it
very hard for an individual to decide
that they want to bargain for their wage
if they think they might just if they're
a part-time a part-time or an agency
work and if they make a fuss and they
just won't be asked back and then
they'll get a reputation for being a
troublemaker so they'll never get to
work again so they have to knuckle under
and work often longer hours in more
intensive ways
for real earnings which are less than
they were ten years ago
and of course the economic aspects of
that the macroeconomic aspects are to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas